the maximum punishment of 20 years
handed down today to the Las Vegas woman
responsible for pushing an elderly man
off a bus causing injuries that led to
his death kadesha Bishop has the
possibility of parole after eight years
the entire incident caused outrage
across the country when video was
released Bishop spoke to the judge
during her sentencing hearing
that
laboratory you know I'm sorry for my
behavior I'm sorry for the win that I
was portrayed in my lowest and weakest
moment of my life you know I wish I
could take it all back little
consolation for the victim's 74 year old
Serge Fournier who passed away as a
result of the injury sustained after he
was pushed by 28 year old kadisha Bishop
in March of 2019 Bishop started yelling
and cursing at passengers on a parked
RTC bus Fournier spoke of in their
defense telling kadisha to be nice to
people
get the [__] out of my face
[Music]
Fournier landed on his head passing away
a month later Bishop steps right past
him without trying to help her attorneys
in court today adding some background to
her mental state Miss Bishop does suffer
from bipolar disorder and she reports uh
PTSD as well and of course these um help
me while never um minimizing the pain of
the the family's loss initially charged
with murder her attorneys in the
prosecution later settled on a deal
to watch the video in light of all that
the state stands by his negotiation with
the defendant
um that she received a 20-year maximum
sentence with her eligibility after
eight I don't believe that you're a
candidate for probation so I'm not
putting you on probation I'm going to
follow the deal that you made with the
state of Nevada
Bishop had her bail revoked initially
after a separate auto theft charge she
has been in jail awaiting sentencing